[Music]
maybe i
flash it up and go with this oh come on
sure nba finals party i need to sign up
on the guest list i left the guest list
to you
i said keep it sophisticated done good
did you invite the kid
you said keep it sophisticated why do
you hate fun you really want me to
invite the kid if i invite the kid then
i got a babysitter
i like the kid i want you to invite the
kids okay can i please shave this off no
you may not because your team lost
therefore you have to look like me
and definitely which one go for third
option
get out friday run a final check on the
party list
question captain steve rogers too soon
sending invites
no way i'm gonna watch the nba finals
with mr stork
so you're gonna let me go ha nice try
buddy
[Music]
oh perfect timing i need to go downtown
and get me snacks for tim duncan
happy the game's starting here faster
than delivery with the whole
thing now remember it's for tim duncan
so nothing fancy just the fundamentals
come on let's go
i'm expecting change
come on come on let's go
you guys are really screwing up my night
just want to watch the game
i think i know that guy
hey hobby kid where are you is mr stark
madam right there devastating
where are the crackers i'm getting them
right now
oh man is there anyone wow
you're dj khaled you're spider-man what
are you doing here i'm going to this
finals party stark's party i'm going to
look can we get a picture sure no
problem come on thank you so much
wow that's definitely a first another
one
another one another one i gotta go out
and watch the game
keep the change can't believe i'm
watching the finals with mrs stark
mj mj called me magic kid
goes for tim duncan he's right over
there
[Music]
it's logan these these are for you
what he wanted to watch the game
you got my change these are great you
wanna try
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
you